der walliser südostwind der rufen hat
zugeschlagen
schnee in rauen mengen hatte gebracht
der einzige weg in swat tal führt durch
die luft wenn das wetter mitspielt der
nebel hängt tief
[Musik]
nation ist wieder vor der fälligkeit dh
im moment auf den lippen
die bauern carney wies das zurück
[Musik]
es wird nicht was ich die problematik
seit jahren hat so etwas nicht mehr
erlebt es hat geschneit wie früher
anderthalb meter in wenigen stunden ist
der berg und natur das macht druck kam
offensichtlich schon pcs horgen
der krisenstab ist aktiviert
[Musik]
alle wollen und wenn er dann mal kommt
ist es auch nicht recht denn zu viel
schnee ist schnell bedrohlich
[Musik]
seit einem tag ist salat von der
außenwelt abgeschnitten es herrscht
höchste lawinengefahr zum ersten mal
wieder seit dem lawinenwinter 1999
der zermatter führungsstab trägt die
ganze verantwortung
in dieser ausnahmesituation hat der chef
der wiener einen alten hasen an bord
geholt bruno
[Applaus]
jelk war während jahrzehnten zermatt
rettungschef er ist eine legende und er
hat ein gespür für schnee und
wird demnach eine entscheidung ob die
liga schaffen oder noch nie geschafft
oder um vorsichtsmaßnahmen muss treffen
dass die dürfe der staat eventuell
sprengen oder was auch immer und dass
die man gemeinsam mit den
verantwortlichen besprechen und nachher
also durchführen
doch jörg sind zurzeit die hände
gebunden das wetter es zu schlecht mit
dem heli dass lawinen gelände
abzufliegen der spezialist
nur für flüge im zahl gibt es
schlupflöcher
13.000 touristen sitzen seit einem tag
im dort fest wer es eilig hat es geht
sobald sich ein wetter fenster öffnet
für 70 franken ist man dabei
wir müssen zurück in die usa wir haben
schon einen flug verpasst und 800 dollar
für die umbuchen bezahlt nun hoffen wir
dass wir jetzt raus kommen
ich habe heute geburtstag und werde
unten erwartet
sowas haben wir noch nie gesehen
das ist ein problem für mich ich bin
hier und muss operieren
in der nacht hörten wir den schnee
fallen wir hatten keine angst fragten
uns aber was da los ist
wir haben heute einen flug nach
australien
murphy liebt helikopter also ist es ein
guter tag
die bilder aus dem wallis gehen um die
welt
[Musik]
im schweizer skiort zermatt sitzen immer
noch rund 13.000 feriengäste fest die
internationale presse reißt sich um das
naturereignis
drei leute hat zermatt tourismus für die
medien freigestellt allen voran gibt die
gemeindepräsidenten romy beer auskunft
also ich
[Musik]
jetzt galt es bewahren das kommunizieren
nach dem anderen zu machen
gemeindepräsidentin so ein medienprofi
inzwischen nach weiß es nicht ich weiß
es nicht auf das richtige machen was
macht nach gefühl
hallo
was sie will uns gegenüber für ein
gefühl hat sie wird bei diesem
medienzirkus mit dabei sind
was die situation ist meine vision so
zum heimlichen und das eigentlich keine
sich das handeln wenn wir es schön wenn
du glaubst dass nicht mehr viel auf
lager das wäre es ist unglaublich was
wohl ganz europa hetzt kühlen zimmer
gibt's nichts mit sachlicher und wie sie
gemacht aus am letzten
augenschein und dort offenbart
fast nicht aus dem letzten loch
als hoch zehn da haben wir die englische
woche circa und handwerk legt
auch die hotellerie ist gerüstet für den
notfall aber
dank der liegt darin dass man gesprochen
im noblen sehr mattenhof kämpft man mit
luxusproblemen und die wären wohl nicht
der rede wert würden wir nicht danach
fragen
mit dem etwas gehört das paar
winterschuhe er knapp vor der bereit
doch regisseur hanspeter
born hier im sommer traf und heidi am
arbeitsmarkt
waschbrett messe wasser das ist vor
allem ist der fall wenn natürlich der
wasserlieferung unterbrochen ist mit dem
zu gott mittelstraße man so eine
maßnahme griff
auf den dorfplatz gibt es zur
aufheiterung der gäste gratis raclette
initiiert von zermatt tourismus und
offeriert von einem hotelier
[Musik]
die straße zurück zum ski war doch
eigentlich wirklich weg war ich einfach
viel zu hoch und selber da zwei stunden
mit klick macht für die geist raum dorf
spazieren und durchstehen krass
feindlichen sind das sehr genossen und
hätten sich leicht merken dass wir
[Gelächter]
sind gut aufgehoben und vertreiben uns
die zeit so gut es geht das was das geht
ziemlich gut das muss man zugeben
möchten das ist noch länger so bleibt
also wir machen alles dass es so bleibt
[Applaus]
euro
[Musik]
die zweite nacht und noch immer keine
zugverbindung nach außen die
lawinengefahr wurde zurückgestuft noch
ist sie aber hoch
[Musik]
der zermatter führungsstab plant den
nächsten tag es ist verrückt ich seit
dem morgen startet achse
frühstücksfernsehen
[Musik]
morgen
mit
in der nacht hat es auf geklagt
[Applaus]
das steht wenn das wasser setzen und
ok aber vorbei zu klein sei bereit das
hier so wie vielleicht dass der
regionale sicherheitsdienst das ist das
brutalste chef und da gibt's beobachter
in jedem jeder klein und mit ihnen
zusammen jetzt das gallego und sie sind
wie eine stabstelle die
profis die fachlich worden nachdem ist
die exekutive
apps vorschlag in der regel eingesetzt
sie sagen
welche straße das erst später und www.la
und und
[Musik]
gut
harry pilot bieten und lawinen
spezialisten arbeiten seit über 30
jahren zusammen
man vertraut sich blind gemeinsam haben
sie am berg schon dem tod in die augen
geschaut
der flug ins hochalpine gelände zeigt
erstmals das ausmaß tischen hängen
[Musik]
von hier oben wird deutlich weshalb der
strom ausgefallen ist
noch in zoos problem ist sie mit strom
stehe die leidliche diese deckt zudem
vertreten
der rallye ist auch taxi für den chef
der grafik songs kraftwerke macht man
einen hals bei der sogenannten zentrale
zimmerte
[Musik]
betriebsleiter im boden wird die anlage
kontrollieren
[Musik]
auch eingeschneite gäste werden nun bei
noch evakuiert das gehört zum service
[Musik]
euro
moderates trinken
[Musik]
und dann geht es runter ins tal die
verschüttete bahnlinie wird exakt
inspiziert
[Musik]
die lawinen hänge sind unberechenbar
was sie etwas schnee oder durch und ohne
namens problem der tür wie dem umland um
die junge garde oder irgendwo das sehr
gut
[Musik]
nach diesem ausführlichen rundflug sieht
der regionale sicherheitschef bruno jelk
klar
ohne neue ära galerie von berisha
lohnausgleich der 45 meter schnee darauf
dass er bereits festgestellt wenn wir
keine
und jetzt will sie sich ein paar
struktur von der bergtour und das geht
sicher für die schätze zur stunde arbeit
bis überhaupt platz frei
die bahn bleibt also vorläufig
geschlossen der exodus der touristen
geht allerdings ungehindert weiter durch
die luft
wir können es kaum erwarten hier
rauszukommen doch wirklich tollen ferien
gab es doch einige überraschung
er kennt den stall drang der touristen
in solchen situationen schiminski
hartberg mit trauschein es langsam panik
und der gemälde geschlossene sie
geschlossen und das sind nicht einfach
nicht gern und der geschäftsmann und
decken und körpertherapie geht aufs
malen schwarz aber das ist normal
wird gemeinderat und krisenstab chef
wiener sind solche zeiten durchaus auch
ein gutes geschäft
stefan sprenger das
ist ceo der air zermatt
[Musik]
er macht nicht ins eckige situationen
ganz extrem wenn man merkt dass
zusammenhalt riesig ist und dass die
bereitschaft der anderen läufern zu
machen da funktioniert man einfach mal
schafft und das ist schon genial wenn
man das gerät
der führungsstab wird entscheiden das
später am tag noch mit dem heli
gesprengt werden soll um den schnee von
den hängen runter zu bringen
[Musik]
mit dem schönen wetter hat sich die lage
dort beinahe schon wieder normalisiert
die versorgung mit der wäsche klappdach
zwei tagen weiter wenn auch erst mit dem
helm
[Musik]
wir müssen nur einmal zentral vom
verkauf die schnitte sind immer noch im
gang
bis 17 das maximum
wie sich das gehört
die öffnung der bahn verzögert sich nun
wollen alle raus
die gelernte pr-fachfrau wiener weiß wie
man leute bei laune hält
die betreuung der gäste wird
hochgefahren
die warteschlangen sind lang
unter dach zu bringen
man findet stunde das gebäude ja aber
das thema
[Musik]
frank nur mit ich habe jetzt das unter
dem titel platziert
im modernen wir jetzt wieder die platte
ist klar dass wir den witz und dann ist
jetzt ja da schaut er unnötig
verschlimmert
da stört will wir bringen jetzt
langsam rage dass die piloten eine pause
macht sich relativ
günstig mit dem bund
danke
sicherheitsexperte bruno jelk macht sich
derweil oben am berg zu schaffen
[Musik]
die munition für die sprengung aus dem
heli ist scharf
der noch wenig später schlägt
[Musik]
sprengmeister hat sich vom einsatz mehr
erhofft
problem ist die passion
bischof zwei dosen
und ein sprecher von heute macht der
tisch der schläfer festigung und der
branche vor schlecht
der ttc jülich
und schnell
werth 74 jährige wird den schnee nicht
aus den augen lassen
guten bescheid gibt es in der
einsatzzentrale
informieren
[Musik]
man musste abwarten halt
sie will ich dass ich es kapitalschnitts
miteinander und das ist enorm wichtig
also ist sie dankbar darum einfach was
ich das kurze zeitfenster war wie heikel
die menge was im biz zur schwierigkeit
gemacht aber schätzte sie warum ihr das
8 meter dankbar
die gemeindepräsidentin gibt unumwunden
zu dass die werbungen der vergangenen
tage unbezahlbar ist
[Musik]
der krisenstab ist aufgelöst
allerdings könnte schon kommende woche
wieder alles anders sein
heftiger schneefall hat sich angekündigt
[Musik]